but we're going to start with this it's
a developing situation for millions in
California due to the latest in a series
of brutal storms they have been hit by
waves of torrential rain causing look at
these shots massive flooding landslides
and power outages more than 30 thousand
people are under evacuation orders and
at least unfortunately 17 people have
died in these storms since late December
Carter Evans is in hard hit Santa Cruz
County that's South of San Francisco
with more on the story Carter good
morning the pictures are amazing to look
at
frightening too yeah and just look at
this behind me I mean this used to be a
beach right here and now it's just a
mess of logs and debris just imagine
what it was like when that huge surf
slammed all this stuff into homes and
businesses further Inland rivers are
swollen and still Rising
even when the rain stops the water is
still there
massive cleanup efforts are underway
just as the state braces for more
drenching storms through next week
across California crews are working to
restore access to highways and Roads cut
off by landslides strong winds knocked
out power to more than 160 thousand
customers
in Santa Cruz County Michael lilitz is
boarding up for the next storm after his
beachfront home was hit by a huge wave
and then this water and debris came in
almost knocked me off my feet so this is
off the 99 look at that car in the
Central Valley the storm damage is
growing in scale
flood waters overtook vehicles and
overwhelmed neighborhoods
same story further south in Santa
Barbara County this rock slide shut down
a highway and our Elise Preston is there
the Earth here is so saturated and many
communities are living on steep
hillsides on residential streets and
Santa Barbara crew spent much of the day
reopening roads closed by mud and
flooding this rock slide shut down a
state highway it will take Crews a while
to clean this mess up
firefighters flew in to rescue a person
trapped by the Ventura river which hit
its highest level ever I've never seen
anything like this in all my 41 years
living in the city we lost their home
and all of ours like belongings that
we've had in Los Angeles flood waters
swamped cars in the mud and the LA River
was up to the brim even some commuters
in Union Station had to get their feet
wet workers ferried others through the
water on a cart
[Music]
let's not forget California is still in
the midst of a severe drought and all of
this rain is helping some reservoirs are
filling up right now but the vast
majority of all this water ends up right
here behind me in the ocean Nate
Carter thank you for